because of what played out i guess in
the media with you
and olivia did you guys at least get to
have a laugh
on set about everything of course yeah
no olivia's
amazing and we um you know we were
filming the season
throughout you know everything going on
i have to say a big congratulations
the new ep is out how are you feeling
first of all i'm feeling really good i
you know
we've had this ep like ready to go it
was supposed to release like six months
ago so now that it's like finally coming
out i'm like all right
and plus i wrote it like over the last
two years
so to finally like get it off my chest
i'm like i'm excited and i just i can't
wait for people to
to hear it yeah it's so funny that you
say that because
initially when these songs started
coming out people thought it was about
a breakup like a breakup album and then
i went through your instagram and i was
like wait
he's literally had these songs written i
mean
a year or so ago so kind of what was
that like for you to have to endure and
also what did inspire
the songs truthfully sure yeah i mean i
think the small
the songs speak for themself that's
really the truth it's funny just
for me to see people like speculate or
make theories about things like
i don't see a lot of it but what i see
i'm like where
are you getting this from like what it's
so funny how people like pieces together
but
you know i get it we're all in
quarantine everybody's got nothing to do
so everyone's trying to
make more meaning out of something than
there is it is funny because i
i did like a google news search and it
was all these oh
is this song is lai lai lai a rebuttal
to driver's license and i wanted to be
like no
it's not yeah it's plain and simple it's
just not
yeah like do do a little homework you
know yeah exactly
like i'm the only one to blame you've
been lying to yourself
like everyone else only thinking about
yourself
what do you hope people learn about you
through these these songs yeah i don't i
don't really know i mean i just hope
they like it i guess uh and
you know they will get to know me by
listening to it um and hopefully some of
it resonates with them and if not then
we'll get them next time
is there a favorite lyric or
song i yeah i mean i think heaven as you
has a special place in my heart
lately i've been questioning my faith
just one look at you is all it really
takes
do it all again is also like a really
special one to me but only a matter of
time i think is probably my favorite
um in terms of like lyrics and just
overall
the whole song i think look me in the
eyes
tell me you're not lying to me see
through your disguise
you can't keep on hiding from me time to
make it right
there's one lyric in there well i'm sure
that you're hurting inside but why would
you make your pain mine
you're making me pay for your crimes
well darling i'll be fine but it's only
a matter of time
i'm sure that you're hurting inside but
why would you make your pain mine is
such a like
you know especially we see this with the
internet all the time you know all the
ways people
say things on the internet um when it's
like
they really most of those people are
hurting and so they feel better
for like 15 seconds because they can
spew that
that garbage they're feeling out onto
somebody else
but in the reality they're just they're
hurting everybody involved have you
felt that with your own social media
have you felt
attacked ever and like how do you handle
that
i mean the reality is like a lot of time
when you
when you read stuff about yourself like
it's so
like a five percent of it is is true if
that and so you
it's almost hard to get upset about it
because you're like there
people are talking about things that
aren't even true so like
you kind of have to remember that and
remove yourself and then also you have
to remember that you know
i think a lot of times people don't
realize the people behind the screens
and you have to remember that people
don't realize the impact that they're
having on you
and when you keep that in mind their
impact is actually not as strong because
it's like
they don't realize that you know how
this hurts me
so with that i can know okay they don't
they they don't uh
you know i can't take it personally that
was like 12 different answers but
um that's the key is just not take it
personally because it's not personal
yeah no i don't think that was 12
different answers i think it was an
important
large answer that people need to be
reminded of
so often when it comes to the internet
and bullying
and spewing hate i think you're
absolutely
right what was the song that was the
most recent song that you wrote
for this was it heaven is you yeah i
think it was heaven as you
yeah i mean i wrote telling myself was
like the newest edition but i i wrote
telling myself like
a year ago um so yeah i think heaven is
the most recently written
when did you write that one i wrote that
one in the summer of last year while i
was
um recording the rest of my ep so yeah
it was kind of like a last minute thing
where
my whole team was like oh well let's uh
let's throw this one into the mix so we
did
what inspired that one you know we're
taught when we're younger that
heaven is this destination that we're
gonna get to but the reality is like
heaven is here on earth and the other
reality is like heaven is you
and it's like you know when you find
that person that is that like idea of
heaven and
you know that is in a physical body like
heaven is you like
it's not this like afterlife world that
we get to you know it's like
in front of me so that was kind of like
the inspiring then just kind of ran with
it
but it's a love song yeah of course
is it about sabrina carpenter
no it is not um but you know people are
going to speculate whatever they're
going to speculate well that's why i
wanted to set the record straight of
people
of course always does she have a
favorite song
on the ep sabrina
um i think she's heard them all i don't
know if she's heard the whole ep
um but i think only a matter of time is
her favorite
okay would you guys ever do it is that
something that you've talked about
i feel like when people date and share a
common interest
in musicality that seems like a natural
thing we just collaborated on
um a song it's it has not come out but
um
yeah i mean again people will speculate
whatever they're gonna speculate but um
we you know we we collaborated on that
and a couple other ideas that we had so
maybe down the road
um we'll you know get together and put
put a song out there but uh as of right
now there are no plans to do that well
when are we gonna hear the song that you
just talked about
you don't know that's a great question i
i don't have a day for you yet no we're
figuring out the time and everything
it's
the time he's not right at the moment
but whenever it is then we will uh
but it is one of my favorite songs i've
ever written and i'm very excited and
proud of the product
changing gears a little bit i do want to
talk about high school musical
the musical the series did i say it
right
why you nailed it um we know that you
guys just wrapped on season two
so first of all how did you celebrate
exciting well
yeah we we all got together socially
distanced and the producer
put on all of the song and dance numbers
from the season
so we all got together and watched that
and it was like the most beautiful
experience
everyone was crying and laughing and
cheering and it was just such a
beautiful
experience despite all the limitations
that we had
we persevered and like we we did this
and so that was a really special moment
at the end i love that what what is in
store for ricky
this season what can you kind of tease
about his journey
yeah i mean look i can't tell you
anything at all because disney will
be down that door but you get to see a
little bit more of the development
of ricky as well as all the other
characters that's what's really cool
about this season is that
we have more time now to sort of see
everyone gets their own world you know
you get to
experience um all the characters lives
and get a little bit of a snippet in
each person so
that's actually really exciting to me
about the second season is just how much
more we get to see into each
character's personal lives and and how
they like intertwine it's really cool
how do you think fans will feel
watching season two i think it's an i
think it's a roller coaster it is such a
a beautiful roller coaster when i was
watching the song and dance number start
to finish that was a rollercoaster for
me i was like
all over the place of motion so i think
i think people are going to have
the right of a lifetime what can you say
about
ricky and nene's
chip in season two if i can't talk about
ricky you you think there's any way i
can talk about ricky and nimi
will fans feel happy watching them this
season
sad they will feel things i'll tell you
that
that's that's a good answer they will
feel they will feel things how does this
i guess compare to season one just
because of the explosion
of a fandom that you guys received after
season one
yeah it's kind of was cool to see like
the reaction and what people resonated
what resonated with people um when they
watched the show going into season two i
think
everyone was just excited to sort of
continue on this
this um this story and honestly i do
believe that season two is like
ten times better than season one and
that's why i'm really excited about it
because i think people who liked season
one are gonna just absolutely adore
susan do
because of what played out i guess in
the media with you
and olivia did you guys at least get to
have a laugh
on set about everything of course yeah
no olivia's
amazing and we um you know we were
filming the season
throughout you know everything going on
and and yeah all is well and we finished
strong and
it was it was really great i love the
maturity and the positivity i think the
world needs more of that so i just want
to commend you
as your career i guess continues to grow
and and blossom how will you continue to
keep
a a good head on your shoulders and
where do you kind of see yourself in
in 10 years yeah i mean i think the key
to keeping the
good head on your shoulders is really
just good people around you can hold you
accountable and who can
be there for you and be a really solid
foundation
uh another key for me is not having
social media on my phone
uh that's super important to me but in
terms of the next 10 years of my career
i think
i don't want to limit myself in any way
i really am like there's so many
ambitions that i have and so many
ideas that i have and i'm super excited
um to explore them
and really just see what happens but i
am excited to see
uh what is next and to keep working on
music and acting and hopefully directing
and writing and all that stuff so yeah
we will see
i i also know that you uh had to go to
the er
a few months ago just want to make sure
a that you're
okay and did that sort of shift your
perspective on
work life balance yeah i mean it's so
interesting
yes i'm okay thank you for asking and
when you go through an experience like
that and you come out
the little things that used to bother
you really can't anymore
like you can it's impossible to get on
social media and get
upset about anything that you see or
anything people are saying like
that stuff just doesn't you have a whole
new perspective on like what really
matters in life and you realize like
that stuff truly is not um what this
whole thing's about
so you know it's easy to let go of that
stuff but yeah i would say it was a
it was a very good growing experience um
and i i am doing better now so thank you
for asking okay good and i am wrapped
so very quickly what are the chances
that we get a full-length album
oh it's coming oh it's coming the full
length is coming
i'm working on it actually right now so
yes it's coming i'm writing and
recording right now
yeah ah amazing so maybe we'll get that
duet on the upcoming album maybe
we'll see you gotta tune in
you